why don't you tell us about your weekend
your fancy weekend with a with in the
club oh you guys I saw a picture use the
club babe what do you mean with so you
know every year well not every year
since the last year starting yeah CA the
agency that Oh my agents they have an
Emmy party so I wasn't gonna go this
year but my agent insisted so um we
can't wait we went to my managers house
we went together us three and we walk in
and um this was a little different it
was in Venice and I know about engines
of the feeling though he didn't feel
like last year it was like or why were
in the club and then like this year and
felt like they what everyone was there I
said Jennifer Aniston I saw Ron Howard I
saw guys
yeah bunch of people so what's your guys
plan of attack is it like we just stand
there find our friends and I let people
come down I tell you exactly our plan of
action yeah we there is food out and
there's giant plates of oysters and
people are supposed to take an oyster
each except we took the whole platter
oyster we find it dark corner
like 50 to worse oysters and you know I
don't there's I am a vegetarian but
twice this week of eating meat yeah to
test out his ligament cake and because I
was so uncomfortable at and at the club
yeah but I was like I'm just gonna sit
here neither Shotaro Easter's it's so
funny because I didn't have that much
fun until the end when I saw Chris
D'Elia like your friends you know it's
so you you're so right cuz it's like
there's so many people around and you
recognized what everyone right yeah but
as soon as you see even me even seeing
Chris D'Elia maybe it was like a water
disease burden
seems like just that it's just that you
go there's my comrade
there's my Chung equally as
uncomfortable yeah Houston it in a
jacket with his hands his pocket
standing the guy and he's out Lagaan
this is incredible guys like outwardly
saying that as a joke yeah right and I
hugged him and we just stood there
because my manager and his manager Becky
Becky were like talking and all that
stuff and then um and then we leave as
we had both up spots and something
wonderful happened this you know we're
at the valet the C's part I have hit
Bobby is facing me I'm facing the cars
coming in so Bobby has his back to the
cars and has his back to guests coming
towards him
I look over out by the car comes Trevor
Noah
because now I'm thinking oh if he
doesn't say hi to Bobby it's gonna
absolutely destroy Bobby because of how
Bobby got his agent to you know you know
help back in the day and stuff but the
first thing Trevor Noah recognized Bobby
from the back and I've never seen more
excited to see Bobby that whole night
and he always maybe just watch Bobby he
turned Bobby's body around yeah he gave
him the deepest hug and then he goes to
his entourage and he tells the whole
story about when he was a kid in South
Africa and he was a nobody how Bobby
called his agent to go see him and how
he basically got his American career
started because of Bobby wow he was
really sweet he remembered it yeah and
it was and he was just and I go yeah I
code and I said nothing it was
inevitable but my point is okay in life
okay is is that it's not that it's just
it was just get to see him because you
have to understand when I was in South
Africa I hung out with her
for two months straight every day yeah
right and he was not the Trevor Noah
that people know today
[Music]